I haven't gotten into the aspects of the
internet in which poetry is involved
it's there and I know some of my
students are into it and I know a lot of
people are it's I allow myself to be
archaic and in that sense I'm the same
poet that Keats was I use a computer but
I basically I'm sitting there with a
piece of paper and the internet is
something there's occasions like this
when one can diffuse oneself in a way
one couldn't but the essence of my life
is still that paper and me
I think certain elements that we have to
remain archaic I mean our personal
relations are always going to be
primitive at best we have to learn to
live with those two on the larger level
I think the fact that we can communicate
across the world that is very very
important than this having is having so
far small repercussions but i think they
yield growth
you